i like you suffer from procrastination
like many other people
suffering quotes uh
how do we avoid procrastination
i don't think the suffer is in
quotes i think that's a huge part of the
problem
is that it's it's treated like a silly
problem
um
it people don't take it seriously as a
dire
problem um
but it can be it can it can
ruin your life
um
there's uh
like talk we talked as we talked about
the compiling
uh concept with you know if you read a
little if you you know you if you okay
if you write if you write two pages a
week
you write a book every two years you're
a prolific writer right and the
difference between you know that again
it's not that that person's working so
hard it's that they have the ability to
when they commit to something like on
sunday mornings i'm going to write two
pages that's it
they
they respect they had they have enough
they have uh they respect the the part
of them that made that decision is is a
respected character in their brain and
they say well that's i decided it so i'm
going to do it
the procrastinator um won't do those two
pages
that's just exactly the kind of thing
the procrastinator will keep on their
list and they will not do but it doesn't
mean they're any less talented than the
writer who does the two pages doesn't
mean they want it any less
maybe they want it even more and it
doesn't mean that they wouldn't be just
as happy having done it as the writer
who doesn't so what they're missing out
on picture a writer who writes 10 books
you know best sellers and they go on
these book tours
and
you know they
and and they just are so gratified with
their career and you know and they
think about what the other person is
missing
who does none of that right
so that that is a massive loss a massive
loss and it's because
um the internal mechanism in their brain
is not doing what the other person is
they don't have the respect for the the
part of them that made the choice they
feel like it's someone they can
disregard and so
to me is this in the same boat as
someone who uh
is obese because their eating habits
make them
obese over time or their exercise habits
um
that you know that's a huge loss for
that person that person is is is you
know the health problems and it's just
probably making them miserable um and
it's and it's self-inflicted right it's
it's self-defeating but that doesn't
make an easy problem to fix just because
you're doing it to yourself so to me
procrastination is another one of these
where you are the only person in your
own way you are comp you know
you are failing at something or not
doing something that you really want to
do you know it does not be work maybe
you're you want to get out of that
marriage that you know you you realize
you hits you you shouldn't be in this
marriage you should get divorced and you
wait 20 extra years before you do it or
you don't do it at all
um
that is uh you know you're not living
the life that you know you should be
living right and so uh
i think it's fascinating now the problem
is it's also a funny problem because
there's short-term procrastination uh
which i talk about as you know the kind
that has a deadline now some people you
know
uh this is when i bring in the there
there's different characters there's
that the panic monster comes in the room
and that's when you actually you know
that the procrastinator can um
there's different levels there's the
kind that even when there's
um a deadline they they stop panicking
they just they given up and they they
really have a problem then there's the
kind that when there's a deadline
they'll do it but they'll wait to the
last second both of those people i think
have a huge problem once there's no
deadline
because and most of the important things
in life there's no deadline which is you
know changing your career uh
you know becoming a writer when you
never have been before getting out of
your relationship um
uh you're gonna be doing whatever you
need to the changes you need to make in
order to get into a relationship there's
the thing after one launching a startup
launching a startup right uh or once
you're once you've launched a startup
firing's the right someone that needs to
be fired right yes i mean going out for
fundraising instead instead of just
trying to you know there's so many
moments when the big change that you
know you should be making
that would completely change your life
if you just did it
uh has no deadline it just has to be
coming from yourself and
um
i think that a ton of people have a
problem
where they
will they they think this delusion that
you know i'm gonna do that i'm
definitely gonna do that you know but
not not this week not this month not
today because whatever and they make
this excuse again and again it just sits
there on their list
collecting dust um
and so yeah to me it's uh
it is a very real suffering and the fix
isn't fixing the habits just uh
uh
i'm still working on the fix first of
all so there's okay
there is um
there's it just say you have a boat that
sucks and it's leaking and it's gonna
sink you can fix it with duct tape for a
couple right you know for one ride or
whatever uh that's not really fixing the
boat but you can get you buy so there's
duct tape solutions
to me so the panic monster is the
character that rushes into the room once
the deadline gets too close or once
there's some scary external pressure not
just from yourself and that's a huge aid
to a lot of procrastinators um again
there's a lot of people who won't you
know do that thing they've been writing
that book they wanted to write but
there's way fewer people who will not
show up to the exam you know most people
show up to the exam so
um that's because the panic monster is
gonna freak out if they don't so you can
you can create a panic monster if you
wanna you know you really wanna write
music you really want to become a
singer-songwriter well book a venue
um
tell 40 people about it and say hey on
you know this day two months from now
come come and see i'm gonna play you
some of my songs you now have a
paintbrush you're gonna write songs
you're gonna have to right so um
there's there's
there's duct tape things you know you
can do things you know people do there's
i've done a lot of this with a friend
and i say if i don't get x done by a
week from now
i have to donate a lot of money
somewhere i don't want to donate and
that's you would put down a category of
duct tape solutions
yeah because it because it's not
why do i need that right if i really had
solved this this is something i want to
do for me it's selfish this is i just
literally just want to be selfish here
and do the work i need to do to get the
goals i want to get right there there's
there's
all the incentives should be in the
right place and yet if i don't say that
i will it'll be a week from now and i
won't have done it something weird is
going on there's some resistance there's
some force that is prevent that is in my
own way right
and so
doing something where i have to pay all
this money okay now i'll panic and i'll
do it so that's duct tape
fixing the boat
is something where i don't have to do
that i just will do the things that i
again it's not
i'm talking about super crazy work ethic
just like
for example okay i have a lot of
examples because i have a serious
problem that i've been working on um and
in some ways i've gotten really
successful at solving it in other ways
i'm still still floundering um so yeah
the world's greatest duct taper
yes well i i i'm pretty good at duct
taping i probably could be even better
and i'm like and i'm and i'm you're
procrastinating and becoming a better
duct tape literally like yes there's
nothing i won't um so
here's what i know what i should do as a
writer right it's very obvious to me is
that i should wake up
don't have to be crazy i don't know 6am
or anything insane or i'm not going to
be one of those
crazy people at 5 30 jogs
i'm gonna wake up at whatever you know 7
30 8 8 30 and i should have a block like
just say nine to noon
[Music]
where i
get up and i just
really quick make some coffee and write
it's obvious because all the great
writers in history did exactly that some
some of them have done that that that's
common there are there's some that i
like these writers they do the late
night sessions but most of them they do
it there's a session but there's a
session that's most writers write in the
morning and there's a reason i i don't
think i'm different than those people um
it's a great time to write you're fresh
right your ideas from the the from
dreaming have kind of collected you have
all you know new answers that you didn't
have yesterday and you can just go
but more importantly if i just had a
routine where i wrote from noon nine to
noon
weekdays
every week would have a minimum of 15
focused hours of writing which doesn't
sound like a lot but it's a lot a 15 15
no this is no joke this is you know
you're not your phone's away you're not
talking to anyone you're not opening
your email you are focused writing for
three hours five that's a big week for
most writers right yes so now what's
happening is that every weekday is a
minimum of a b i'll give myself you know
a might be you know wow i really just
got into a flow and wrote for six hours
and had you know great but it's a
minimum of a b i can keep going if i
want and every week is a minimum of a b
with those 15 hours right and if i just
talk about compiling if i this is the
two pages a week if i just did that
every week
i achieved all my writing goals in my
life and yet i wake up and most days i
just uh either i'll revenge
procrastination late at night and go to
bed way too late and then wake up later
and get on a bad schedule and i just
fall into these bad schedules or i'll
wake up and there's just you know i'll
say i was gonna do a few emails and i'll
open it up and i'm suddenly on text and
i'm texting and or i'll just go and you
know i'll make a phone call and i'll be
on phone calls for three hours it's
always something yeah or i'll start
writing and then i hit a little bit of a
wall but because there's no sacred this
is a sacred writing block i'll just hit
the wall and say this is icky and i'll
go do something else
so duct tape what i've done is um uh
wait but why has one employee alicia
she's the manager of lots of things
that's her role um she truly does lots
of things um
and one of the things we started doing
yeah is
either she comes over and sits next to
me where she can see my screen from nine
to noon
that's all it takes the thing about
procrastination is usually they're not
kicking and screaming i don't want to do
this it's the feeling of you know in the
old days when you had to go to class you
know your lunch block is over and it's
like oh [ __ ] i have class in five
minutes or it's monday morning you go ah
yeah but you said you know what but you
know you go you say okay and then you
get to class and it's not that bad once
you're there right
you know you have a trainer and he says
okay next set you go okay and you do
that's all it is it's someone some
external thing being like
okay i have to do this and then you have
that moment of like it sucks but i guess
i'll do it if no one's there though the
problem with the procrastinator is they
don't have that person in in their head
other people i think were raised with a
sense of shame if they don't do stuff
and that stick in their head
is hugely helpful i don't really have
that um and so
anyway alicia is sitting there next to
me
it's not she's doing her own work but
she can see my screen and she of all
people knows exactly what i should be
doing what i shouldn't be doing
that's all it takes the shame of just
having her see me while she's sitting
there not working would just be it's too
weird and too embarrassing so i get it
done and it's amazing it's a
game changer for me so duct tape can
solve sometimes duct tape is enough but
i'm curious to i'm still trying to what
is going on yeah
i think part of it is that we are
actually wired i think i'm being i'm
being very sane human actually is what's
happening you're not saying it's not the
right word i'm being like
i'm being a natural human that we are
not programmed to sit there and do
homework of a certain kind that we get
the results like
six months later like that is not
so we're supposed to con you know
conserve energy and like fulfill our
needs as we need them and like do
immediate things
and
um we're overriding our natural ways
when we wake up and get to it and i
think sometimes it's because the the
pain i think a lot of times we're just
avoiding suffering and a lot for a lot
of people the pain of not doing it is
actually worse because they feel shame
so if they don't get up and take a jog
and get up early and get to work i'll
feel like a bad person
and that is worse than doing those
things and then it becomes a habit
eventually and it becomes just easy
automatic it just becomes i do it
because that's what i do
you